80 percent of women want 20 yeah go for
20 percent of men but i'm saying men
that are in prison
reproduce more like have more kids than
men that aren't yeah so to me that says
something about women's ability to pick
like we're not very successful
defend the male aspect of it when i do
understand where she is coming i do
understand where you're coming from
the at the same time you do have to
understand that it's like the evidence
you're giving there's a massive global
and then there's how many people are
actually in jail and then that might be
the 20
in that jail with actually is targeted
by the eighty percent i've said this
i've said this in the previous podcast
this is this is kind of like exactly the
same theory as like if um i've said this
to people but i'm murdered by my
boyfriend whereas like if you've seen
the documentary it's a real documentary
so basically a guy meets the guy meets a
girl it was all nice and whatever like
you know he showed a good side of him
that's how she got that's how he got her
and then later on that's when the
domestic violence came in the more of
the story at the end of it she got
murdered by she they had a kid and they
now she was like kind of forced to stay
with him did he stay with him then they
kind of split apart and then they got
back together and then the the end of
the story was um she got killed by her
boyfriend in her house with a ironing
board that's a that's a true i remember
this i remember this
but it happens a lot i think so
definitely
so what do you want for women do you
want them
to take accountability yeah
because i just think we live in a world
where women don't take accountability
and i can see it like when we're talking
because every time i say like women need
to do something better there's always an
excuse
and so it's like why is that i say women
should be careful who they sleep with
that should be agreed no women should
agree women should stop picking men in
prison
[Music]
women women should be responsible with
who they sleep with and and
and there it really shouldn't be an
excuse to get pregnant because there's
so many forms of contraception but
that's different
and so and then you think capitalized
societies do you know what i mean like
it's so inhumane of us to just think
okay cool like i'm just going to think
of the uk and the us and well-developed
countries when there's like a ridiculous
amount of other countries that don't
have at all the
mindset the the resources nothing the
society that we even have to even
develop i would i would guess that we
have more abortions than those countries
honestly because we have the lack of it
right or it's because like it's because
of our values as a society like it's me
me me me me it's like i don't want the
um i i'm too broke to have this kid it
would like it would be too much of an
inconvenience to my life it's not the
right time it's me me me me me where
other societies vam you felt family and
culture like a little gun i was going to
say look at the amount of in developing
countries look at the amount of children
who are born of rape who have who become
hiv babies and things like this but
exceptionally in that aspect because it
actually happens in some in some
third world countries it's acceptable
yeah which ones
um for example
even south korea right south um is this
no north korea is like that there's
there's i've i've heard i even think
what a dignity
i think abortion is the least of their
problems in north korea yeah it's like
that's what there's there's also there's
just it's just me trying to there's
quite a value at my point yeah there's
quite a few african countries too like
within africa within like 70 years rape
i think it's like 60 grand great great
yeah it's insane
it's just so like it's it's very it's
very high and what i think the point
that you're trying to make is that we
cannot just look at this obviously in
this case we're discussing because this
is to do with america yeah we're saying
in general there is a larger argument
right for uh for abortion than than and
to do with contraception as well like
contraception is really not readily
available in a lot of developing well
but i'm saying like we keep moving the
goal posts but like
but but it is because i said in the
beginning no because i said in the
beginning we're talking about the us and
the uk
and so then it's like when that argument
starts to go it's like we move the goal
post okay but i don't think i don't
think the argument has gone because i
think what we're saying we're still
saying that you're still reiterating the
same point and we're still reiterating
the same point you're saying you know
there's so much contraception available
and we're saying actually for a lot of
people that contraception isn't
accessible isn't it free in the uk yes
it is free in the uk yes
condoms are damn near for you can get
them no condoms are free condoms are
free no but she's talking about in
america i i i
suppose like i i'm saying this as
someone i have really i have really good
insurance in like not just like like one
insurance i have really good insurance i
go to like
um
you have health care
and that's like do i
no like youtube
good health care and
in that like
i've never i've never like this is not
something that is really available i i
and and this i should have the resources
when i am able to afford these things
but if i as someone who is able to
afford these things right have not been
given this obviously i have because my
mom like
raised me like and that's the thing like
my mom has been able to provide these
resources for me but take me out
and
you have to acknowledge that a lot of
people in america do not have the
resources and if i am saying if i'm on
the privileged side and have not been
given access outside of my own mother
like my own home providing more for me
and a lot of people can't provide for
themselves or like you know the health
care because here in the uk nhs like
yeah sure it's free on that side but in
america a lot of times i know i think
birth control is free for certain people
or depending on the insurance you have
like my insurance is free but that is an
exception on the on the site that most
americans are impoverished okay so
do you really you do you think that
condoms are unaffordable for the lower
class
or do you think they choose not to use
them
i think it's both i think it's both and
i'm not saying that to sideway either i
think that it is a good thing to be
looked at um to actually analyze i see
something
keep going i'm listening yeah but i
think it is like
i think some people are like choosing
not to and it's always going to be some
people that don't care but then there's
also people 24 for 12 pounds yeah but
that's even england but then i'm i'm
going to the fact of in america yeah
more people are impoverished and you
can't you can't be naive to say that no
majority of people are are not and but
it all goes down to like what you really
want in life because sure if you saved
like a few more dollars then sure you
could afford that but so i think i think
you can afford it yeah so so wouldn't
you agree it's more of a choice i don't
think contraception's the argument we
should look at i think at the heart of
this is is education because they've
already shown so
for reference well does that all go to
resources the secondary school though we
just we sort of agreed to finish sorry
the secondary school that i went to had
the highest teen pregnancy rate in the
whole of europe that was my secondary
school yeah quite an impressive figure
where did you go the dalkin technology
college in swindon
um and they held it for many years yes
swindon
where the hell is that
trust me
but my point is is that good things
which also ties into the fact that my
school had some of the lowest grades in
nationwide
[Music]
we see that in people who are more
educated
people who are more privileged have had
a better education better schooling
they have lower rates of especially teen
pregnancy and unwanted pregnancies
that's not a coincidence a lot of the
schools which have the worst education
they suffer a lot on things which are
not classed as essential such as we call
it pshe in england which is like covers
a lot of sex ed and also just general
female female health and male health in
terms of like um periods and things like
that too
but
if you have access to that education for
some some people aren't eve i remember
sat in this ph pshe class this girl
didn't know she was 15 years old didn't
know
how many holes you had didn't know that
you she like she she hadn't she
she hadn't yet had her period and she
thought that it came out your bum mm-hmm
like she
so but but we laughed but people
genuinely don't know yeah
if people aren't
home then people need to be taught in
schools but if you are as a school
pushing abstinence whilst also trying to
crack down on abortion you're arguing
two different things here because if you
tell people if you educate people
properly on how to have safer sex the
statistics show you are less likely to
have unwanted pregnancies whereas if you
only educate abstinence don't have any
sex and you don't teach the rest you
have higher cases that's not true
there's no evidence that indicates that
sex ed is an effective form of
preventing pregnancies there are more
abortions now than there were before sex
ed and no this is this is what i'm
saying i went to a catholic school we
they did preach abstinence we had no
teenagers privatize school so like
you're getting a better you're getting
over a better education i i went to and
i'm saying like say as far as on the
health side i'm saying that i can ask
you one question real quick so do you
really think that most people sleep like
having sex in high school don't know
what condoms are do you some people and
that person like what percent if you go
like out of every 10 kids having sex
it goes down to a socio-economic level
because if you're
public school not not private school
because you went to a private school so
that's a totally different totally
different realm but if you are looking
at private schools private
public schools are funded on a
socio-economic level so although they
are all
government schools if this neighborhood
is uh has a revenue of of five right
yeah so you're only going gonna have
five p to put back into the school yeah
whereas a school that i went to i went
to like a very wealthy
public school we didn't talk about these
things like we kind of did but i think
like most of the people in the room were
on the advantage of having those but i
will say that there are people that did
not have like these conversations at
home or were not able to they didn't
have these resources and so i think is
is very ignorant to say yeah well like
everyone should no everyone shouldn't
because everyone doesn't have the same
um socioeconomic like so so you think
people from a lower socioeconomic
background they a lot of them don't know
what condoms are no
it's not not not that condoms overall
but like
safe sex
yes like these things are not being
taught and if you assume
i assume you're making an ass out of you
and me so just
no no no
you that's that's literally what it is
because
i can't i can't just go into a situation
and assuming that i know everything
that's why in different situations you
have to make sure that everyone is on
the same page so if there's no way or
nowhere along the lines that we like sit
down and say hey where are you at where
are you at and making sure that we're
all like say how we're in this
conversation right now unless that we
know for sure
that we've had the opportunity and given
everyone a space to identify what is
what and say yeah how they feel you can
never say oh well yeah oh you really
think these people aren't educated yes i
really do think these people aren't
educated because no one ever sat down
and had a conversation and said well i
know this at my socioeconomic level and
this school knows this like no there's
no way and it's just blissfully ignorant
to say that you think that everyone has
no everyone doesn't and it goes to the
fact of socioeconomic like
public schools are okay
on that like do you get what i'm saying
public schools have more sex ed than
private schools so wouldn't you know it
would be more educated it wouldn't be
more educated no because if you're so
wait wait can i can i ask you a question
you don't think if one school has sex ed
and one school doesn't have sex ed
though the school with sex ed would have
more education on it you can do biology
and that covers what you should cover
you know
they have actual like sex ad in public
schools they don't have them in private
schools they don't actually have them in
private schools but if you're period not
okay but let's not catholic i mean i
don't i don't know about
take the subject out if the subject like
no matter the subject if the subject all
around math science whatever if the
subject is not being funded at all how
can you say oh well yeah you all it's
like that's where you go into from
equality to equity because sure they all
had the same opportunity but they were
not giving the same advantages so
it you it just
you've also just admitted yourself a
really good point of like you're
speaking on behalf of catholics
that's what i'm saying i i'm on the same
we were both privileged in this
situation i started out in private
school because my mom wanted me to have
the best opportunity and then like
but that is not most people are in
public schools and that's why i'm
emphasizing on the point of
socioeconomic impact and then in this
because of these socio-economic impacts
like that are funding the public schools
it goes from
these schools are all equally public
schools so they have the resources i
understand i understand there's a
difference in like there's a difference
in funding for schools but what i'm
saying is i think most poor people know
what condoms are okay
i think it's kind of condescending to
insinuate they don't know
like that's sort of like like okay poor
people argument about like sex ed and
like learning about these things so if
no i've been asking you okay like
regardless of the argument guys one more
time please you're not answering her
question
sorry the last okay i'll i'll say this
and then after this you can cut me off
okay but the last thing that she was
saying is that um
[Music]
you're you're cutting off saying like
teaching safe sex while saying no
abortion so at some point you have to
do more here
to decrease here so if you're not doing
more of sex ed
then you can't like but what what
evidence do you have that sex ad
decreases abortions
and i've i've read books on like them
bringing in sex ed into schools that's
the only reason i know this i don't i
don't expect like you to i probably
would think the same thing look at
holland holland has
rated one of the best sex educations in
the world and they have one of the
lowest rates of teen pregnancy they have
some of the lowest rates of stds
have you seen some of their laws like
that
what what are some of their laws i don't
know but they're crazy my uncle monk
used to work then
it's like when you have children there's
like it's it's it's weird i don't know
exactly what the laws are but like i've
heard it right are you saying lose at
first no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no i meant to say like in
a sense of like
when in holland it's like when you have
a child or something like you should the
laws are very like
i want to say strict
how it is in the us but i know in the uk
even i'm just talking from my own school
and obviously some of my friends have
been to different schools um before they
teach sex ed um
they actually give a form to you to give
back to your parents and they actually
say okay mom dad are we allowed to teach
your child sex ed yes no if so what can
we teach them there's like sections abc
whatever the hell it is i don't even
remember because my mom didn't give me
that privilege of going to see a
freaking sex i think so i didn't
actually know
a lot until i was around what 15 yeah do
you know what i mean and i can probably
say the same about my little sister so
my mum never told me
my mum probably told me where the baby
comes out of because i probably asked
that question but when it comes huh what
story did you get
oh it came out yeah
yeah yeah um so
i never got any talk about the stds any
talk about health like health
precautions that you need to take i
didn't even know
how honest to god i didn't know how to
shave my down down there until i was
like what bro you got tired of school no
no i'm saying my mum didn't allow me to
watch sex ed but yet she didn't really
teach me the fundamentals of
sexual harassment do you know what i
mean so it's like
were you wild then
girl
no
no it took me a while it took me a while
i'm
were you a wild teenager i was not
without the sex that's that's crazy no
i'm like i wasn't but my mom was quiet
no i actually wasn't i was like i didn't
have conservative i was quite everyone
was yeah you know what i mean that was
just they're like this is intriguing
like what is going on you know what i
mean but my mom's quite conservative in
the way where she i personally think she
finds it uncomfortable to talk about
certain things right no i yeah so when
it comes down to actually having sex ed
a lot of parents wouldn't tick yes
because they are uncomfortable for some
for their child to know that did you
know what a condom was
honestly i
couldn't i tell you i knew what uh i
didn't even know a guy's penis looked
the way it did until i didn't either
until no until i saw obviously when porn
was introduced corn was introduced to me
but um thank you thank you
um but um
i honestly i do feel like i like the
value in sex ed and obviously because of
my sexuality didn't lead me to have a um
heteronormative
baby yeah do you know what i mean so so
it's kind of like
yeah you can say public schools had sex
ed but also you have to look at how
it was back at home
and the the information and the family
construct you have back at home as well
well it just it just seems like that's
what i think it's more the family and
the values you raise with your family
yeah okay and that's why that's why like
it goes back to like
like values yeah like okay regardless of
like contraception and education like
back to the point of like just abortion
in general so imagine if everyone's
educated but everything you need to know
about sex yeah and everyone knows
do you still feel like abortion should
be allowed
like for everyone it's a question for
everyone so if everyone knows
exactly what will happen yeah if you
don't have safe sex and everyone is
educated like the best that you can does
everyone still believe that
we should allow abortion i still feel
like there should be a choice
yeah
i still think that um
yeah i still think that abortion should
be allowed yeah even if regardless of
like even if it's like yeah i don't care
it's not my business it's like if i
choose not to do it then that's that
that's for me but i can't decide for the
next person and i believe i believe in
the bible so that's why i don't believe
in it for me but i'm not to tell the
next person because according to the
bible all sins are equal and then also
if you're looking at it on the stance of
the amendments um america was founded on
separating church and state so if the
the foundation is saying that religion
right
and the laws should be separated why are
you infringing your religious views on
those because to me it's not about
religion it's about biology but unique
can i finish
they have a unique dna sequence from the
second they're conceived basically
that doesn't mean that they um
are a human being and the it's created
to me how you can your brain starts
formula
immediately no i understand but you it's
crazy brain activity at three weeks
exactly
you're also very much shaped by your
upbringing and your religious upbringing
everyone is
so but so does your v your views are
colored by the way you were everyone's i
was raised catholic but i was raised to
for for not like the only sex education
i had was being shown a picture of what
gonorrhoea looked like in school right
right but i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying it like
you know but i'm saying it's not really
relevant like what your upbringing was
it what's relevant is i think it's
always relevant
why the what's relevant it is one at a
time it's what's relevant is is it right
or is it wrong but you're like you're
basing that off of your religious views
no like because no i'm i'm like you're
moral
on your religion no right but she said
no i'm saying it's not it's not based
i'm not even that religious of a person
to be honest i'm not like a bible
thumper i don't
like no
no i'm not like i'm not like a super big
bible thumper like i'd consider myself
christian but i'm not like but it's
crazy but can i finish but i'm saying
like like i just i genuinely believe
that's a life and i believe that's
murder so that's not not a religious
belief
that's based on that's based on an and i
have a brother that my my parent gave up
for adoption and i've seen adoption work
in my family